the Ministry of Agriculture in
collaboration with the Taiwan technical
Mission hosted a training session on the
proper cultivation techniques and ways
of combating major Pest and diseases of
five varieties of okra inclusive of
three local varieties and two newly
introduced varieties Oka is one of the
focal crops under the second phase of
the seven crops project which has the
overall aim of reducing the food import
bill of St Lucia the two newly
introduced varieties were carefully
selected for the adaptability to St
Lucia's climatic conditions which will
increase yields across the island and
are expected to have higher resistance
to Pest and diseases technical
production officer attached to the seven
crops project Edward Wilson explains
that the project goal is to focus on the
diversification of the market and
increase cultivation on the farms we're
having a orro training it's a Vari
training um we've invited Farmers from
around the island from the different
regions to participate in the training
the focus mainly here is is just the
introduction of new varieties you know
we want to have that diversification in
the market what Farmers um are used to
and to introduce some varieties which
will cope better with the climatic
conditions on island and that will
increase production for the farmers in
an effort to educate farmers and
consumers alike on proper cultivation
techniques and nutritional benefits and
okra production manual was published to
illustrate how creatively utilize each
okra variety these manuals can be found
at the union Orchid Garden Taiwan
technical Mission office we're also
trying and publish an
okro a production Book for a manual a
grin manual cultivation manual for that
both the green and varieties to show
farmers and also consumers how to
exactly use the product because um
heating the red variety of uru is not
the right way of course if you're
heating that you're going to diminish
the nutritional um aspect of that so it
has to be consumed almost raw taking
note of continuous success of the seven
CRS project the Ministry of Agriculture
maintains its dedication to improving
the San agriculture sector by working
alongside its development Partners to
augment research activities and services
in an effort to ensure full
participation and empowerment of Agri
food constitu on the island from the
Ministry of Agriculture Fisheries food
security and rural development I am Zar
fix reporting